now I have noted on social media that I
am tired of being told that I'm going to
be shown something and then like Lucy in
the football
I never managed to make contact with the
football and as a science it's a PhD in
stem I feel Duty bound to report that I
have been spun up several times only to
be wound down and told that it's got to
be deferred because of some meeting or
some change in plans so I have no idea
whether this Outreach is a form of
disinformation in which well-meaning
individuals are constantly put in some
sort of
tantalus-like situation
um
was one of those invitations to go to
skinwalker oh I've I've had multiple
invitations to go to skin marker from
Brandon
okay and have you taken him up on that
no I haven't and for reasons that you
may find amusing
um
one of the things that I did was consult
with some people about the safety issues
of this UFO stuff and they said
um
things that I wasn't really prepared for
one of which a particular individuals
said to me
there is absolute tissue damage that we
can record
um that comes out of stories of
encounters and you make what you want of
the encounter story but it is completely
consistent with
our biopsies and our understanding of
what cell death has occurred
which I found really interesting I mean
here I'm talking to published scientists
it sounds like evidence it sounds like
evidence
but my point would be whether or not I
understand that as aliens or whether or
not I understand that is that there's a
uranium deposit or who knows what
I I don't know enough about
secret weapons or geology or or who
knows what yeah you know I do know that
I've been warned
um
that bad things happen to people who get
too close to some of this stuff
well it doesn't stop them filming a TV
show there uh yeah I I Brandon actually
invited me it may not stop me from going
out either yeah no Brandon has invited
me maybe we should go together and then
we can uh compare notes uh Brandon has
invited me
and I have not I recently reached out to
him to try to stick up on him but is
being like busy and hasn't really got
back to me yet but you know I would
still like to go to Skinwalker and if
you're interested I'm potentially
willing to consider it off air I asked
Mick if he would be willing to engage in
so-called ce5 that is Close Encounters
of the fifth kind if someone offered to
perform it with him and time was
sufficiently limited travel paid for it
was done by someone known for their
consistency and disregard Etc as this is
a technique which purportedly reliably
induces quote-unquote contact Mick
responded I would go I think there are
probably no Supernatural phenomenon or
visiting aliens but if I'm going to
criticize something then it's only fair
that I try to fully understand what
people are experiencing by observing
them experiencing it and maybe even get
a sense of it for myself
there's some topics I would love to
actually hear your take on as an expert
because I'm not one
one thing I found very distressing about
this whole topic is I was willing to
reconsider my UFO position
separately from attended positions which
I don't really want to get into so the
first thing that's very hard to separate
off is this cattle mutilation claim
right yeah so in other words you think
you just want to talk about
um yeah
actually I'll go in later to the issue
about why I'm interested in UFOs
for for scientific reasons but
something some that you just want to
talk about UFOs you get into cattle
mutilation and then you get into
progressively weirder and weirder
sounding stuff that I'm not excited
about the least exciting thing for me is
this remote viewing stuff
right it's interesting from a historical
perspective say more from the the
actions of the government the government
did Research into remote viewing and in
reaction to the Russians doing research
into remote viewing I believe back in
the 50s or 60s project Stargate and this
was a real thing so I think you know
even though it's something that sounds
kind of
somewhat ridiculous it's something
that's actually bubbled its way to the
top in a way that you know UFOs are
bubbling their way up now it's uh it's
something that's you know Men Who Stare
at Goats the film is based on on real
real events so you know these these
things they they don't sound interesting
and they're a bit silly
but they had consequences if the door is
open for UFOs being a real phenomenon
whatever Place brackets and to say it's
an extraordinary phenomenon then
why does that not open the door to other
extraordinary phenomenon which is also
attested too by high-ranking individuals
and there are government studies such as
remote viewing why is it provoking an
unfavorable reaction from you I I don't
know whether you saw my interaction with
Hal put off on the topic of predicting
the markets
yeah so why don't you
well no it was a bit more subtle than
that
um his claim was is that he was able to
predict the markets in order to
effectively replace a bake sale or
something at a local school
and by getting 10 he could make somebody
else I forget 260 000 and he could get
twenty six thousand dollars which is all
he needed then he stopped predicting the
markets yeah the typical energy around
that would go like dude if you could
become rich why wouldn't you do it yeah
right that's not my energy
my energy is the evidence my energy is
if you could do this reliably you could
settle so many debates by proving like
you assume you don't care about money
and assume whatever this that and the
other thing
you do care about credibility
and you could increase your credibility
by inviting people onto your private jet
to take you to your private islands etc
etc
by just doing this relentlessly and then
that conversation didn't go anywhere now
if you notice in
Jesse's cut of that interaction
I stayed on that point doggedly
um and and he cut a lot of it out but
you see him say this thing where he says
like I think we've I think we've
addressed this issue
um
but I was always trying to be
polite I was not trying to take how
the task in a way that led him
look ridiculous I was you know I I find
this claim disturbing
like you I don't want to let these
claims in if they Cloud our judgment
it's very important to me that we not
have nonsense claims
I don't want to say he's a liar I don't
want to say I believe this to be true I
don't know what to make of it I'm
probably backing off of it before I do
more damage
I don't like
these other claims Kurt
because the cattle mutilations are the
ones that are closest to sounding like
UFOs
and the remote viewing
sounds like a different Force carrier in
other words if you imagine that you and
Kurt where are you currently Toronto
Toronto yeah and Mick you are in
Sacramento Sacramento so somehow we're
all having this conversation on a screen
in real time almost
and this is only possible because of
photons and electrons
imagine that there are new Force
carriers like photons that can be used
to transmit information that can go
through I don't know sea water who knows
what it's possible that you could get a
new physics to explain remote viewing
and that microtubules are in you know
antenna in the brain blah blah blah it's
not completely outside of the realm of
possibility but it's also pretty
far-fetched
right and
it's important to be able to say this
sounds like total nonsense without
necessarily needing to destroy somebody
in the process
yeah and it sounds like nonsense I think
you're you know you're polite uh sorry
uh you're polite questioning of how
putoff was was the right thing you were
pressuring him there and it's not really
about why don't you use this to make
loads of money because you know you
could very easily give a reason why you
don't need the money it's it's why don't
you demonstrate this this amazing new
physics or this amazing new phenomena to
science if remote viewing was actually a
demonstrable thing it would be one of
the most incredible Revolutions in
science in um you know ever really it
would be as you just describe perhaps a
new force of physics an entirely new
understanding of Consciousness in the
brain uh it would be a big deal and yet
halputoff is just like um yeah I kind of
got bored of doing that and
didn't took too much time I wanted to do
other things it was it seemed ridiculous
I couldn't understand the answers that
came back yeah yeah
Mick do you see remote viewing as
equally far-fetched as taking UFOs
seriously is some extra
ordinary phenomenon I I see it as
equally unbased in evidence you know if
it's if it's something that could be
done it would be huge and you know to
that extent you can understand why
people in the military perhaps people
with a little bit of magical thinking uh
went for it if you hear that the
Russians are doing something and they're
having success doing something you know
you know obviously the
intelligence wasn't quite as uh as good
as you might might like you're getting
these these things out of Russia then
yeah why not stick a team on trying to
figure out whether it's real or not but
neither the Russians found anything nor
the nor the Americans let me come up
with a plot a more plausible explanation
we know that for example Leon Thurman
who discovered the
capacitance as a musical instrument
which Bears his name
uh was in the Sharia prison system
um which is these country club prisons
for like stem Geniuses to work on Soviet
projects well well in prison and he came
up with if I'm not mistaken a means of
watching the vibrations of a window pane
and using it as a microphone so that you
could tell what was going on in the U.S
embassy for example
and you know I believe there was also a
plaque that was a listening device
imagine you had lots of ways in to
listening to the Americans inside of the
Russian Embassy more broadly
I would easily think about developing
remote viewing as an explanation for how
how could they have known that yeah
right yeah it could be a fine cover
story because you would actually be able
to tell what conversation somebody was
having in private yeah um as a result
they're using magic to explain the way
they're earning competence in a way that
that plaque that you referred to was on
the wall for I think you know several
years before they discovered it had a
microphone in it and so they know that
secrets were getting out and rather than
actually go down the actual real route
of like sweeping their Embassy for bugs
they started perhaps you know there's
this kind of magical thinking that
remote viewing was real and we should
investigate it so in such a case I would
understand why there would be a story
and this is one of the reasons that
I think a lot of these stories got
formed in a time before the internet
and so the problem with a story like
this is is that you can
it was easier to keep brittle structures
of narrative together before there were
so many people chiming in and you could
crowdsource data or understandings of
what was going on and that's that's
what's happening I think to a degree now
with whenever
the secret evidence comes out it gets
examined by a very large number of
people and quite often gets resolved and
when that happens it essentially reveals
the incompetence of the people who have
been looking into it like there's this
green triangle uh video that's been
knocking around for quite some time your
lens aperture point or yeah yeah and
it's it's basically been you know 100
conclusively shown the this is just an
artifact of the camera and the vast
majority of the the green triangles in
this video were just Stars and yet we
have uh statements and leaks uh that uh
say that they thought that these stars
in the sky that appear triangular were
actually some kind of flying craft and
and even some kind of flying triangular
craft
but when it gets released and especially
the high quality video when that gets
released it's pretty much apparent what
it is to people who who are familiar
with these things so you know someone
made the argument that perhaps you know
they're not releasing this data partly
because they don't want to be shown up
they're afraid of the things being
solved and them looking stupid which is
kind of what happened with this green
triangle thing you know the the lead
scientist of the UOP task force Travis
Taylor he didn't think that they were
they were uh stars and then I kind of
explained it to him in a bit more detail
and now he's changed his mind and now he
thinks that they are but you know for
years the UAP task force was laboring
under this misapprehension that these
these flying uh these flying things were
green triangles when they were in fact
identifiable stars that we can name and
show on a star map so there's a real
issue there of cover your ass which
might be uh cooling things down a little
well one of the one of my questions is
why do we not have our best people
on this and this was my point I think
where you and I came in contact in some
sense in Twitter where I was saying
if somebody is claiming that we cannot
control airspace that is sensitive from
a military perspective
um
is that what they're climbing though I
mean they're not claiming we can't
control it they're claiming that we
occasionally see things in there that we
can't identify and we we haven't
determined that they are you know under
control by an intelligent entity
uh so it's more of an issue of we have
clutter in our airspace and we don't
know what it is you and I have heard
different things
I have heard that we cannot control our
airspace
that these things are not that uncommon
that
these are actually
um much more frequently found near
sensitive military installations and
exercises that they can potentially turn
off and on nuclear devices wow that's
these are these are claims Beyond
there how do I even put this
one of the things that you don't know
about in this world until you actually
start talking to people
is which of these stories are highly
conserved through people who don't seem
to even know each other
right so for example let me just take
two sets of triangular pyramid-like
issues there is apparently
a configuration of a craft
like people who chart these things say
that a lot of these UFOs look very
dissimilar but that there are clusters
of things that seem to be highly
conserved over decades one of these
conserved things is supposed to be a
flat equilateral triangle with three
lights in its uh slightly recessed from
its vertices with round rounded points
okay then you have this thing with the
fact that the way that these lenses open
and close is with you know some sort of
and Nick you you'll have the right
terminology for these sort of
interlinked
um
the leaves of the IRS I didn't have the
word leaves so that somehow the leaves
create triangles and then you have this
Confluence between people who claim to
have seen a very conserved triangular
craft and something that shows up as a
triangular blotch of light and then you
have people who are willing to swing at
any pitch because they're willing to say
oh well that's that thing that was
spotted over Belgium or was it
Montevideo or who knows what you just
watched a clip from the theories of
everything channel for the full video
and all its magnificence then click here
and if you'd like to see more then
subscribe enjoy